All right, here we are the last day of March, 2021.
It's a beautiful day in Minnesota,
chilly a little bit back down into the 30s and 20s.
We're supposed to get back up into the 70s,
which is unseasonally warm for this tummy year for us.
I hope you are experiencing great and sunny days
in your deck in the woods as well.
So we have some things to go over.
And again, what we go over in these PowerPoints,
or in this first part of this Zoom call are things,
questions that people have emailed in.
So again, if you have questions that you want us to address,
maybe in a little bit more detail and a picture or something like that,
then make sure you email those in just please put in the subject line,
Zoom call question so that it doesn't get lost and we can get in it.
So let's jump into it.
And let's talk about the questions that came in.
People asked about Rick Simpson oil for topical use.
So we had a question coming in.
Can you use Rick Simpson oil for topical things?
So let's talk about, first of all, what Rick Simpson oil.
Rick Simpson oil is this.
It's not really an oil.
It's like a black tar in consistency.
It is a high concentration THC.
It's very viscous, very thick.
And that's why it's put in these syringes because you syringe it out,
either into a capsule and take it orally in a capsule,
or Rick, Rick Simpson used to do its name after a guy named Rick Simpson,
who really kind of invented this.
How did this still down?
I'm going to give you an anonymous THC so that you get this highly concentrated THC substance
that can be beneficial to help with your body killing cancer.
You have to be very careful with this.
It is sold legally in some places that sell states that have marijuana sales and CBD and THC sales legally.
It is available in other areas as well.
You don't sell it at the clinic.
But Rick Simpson oil is this concentrated THC substance that he used to suggest that you syringe out the size of a grain of rice onto your finger.
And then you have to literally scrape it off your finger with your teeth.
It tastes very ashy like tarry ashy taste to it.
It will make you a little loopy depending on the dosage that you're doing.
But it could have some great benefits, not just as a quote-unquote cancer killer,
but it could help you sleep, it could help take pain away, it has some other great benefits using it topically.
So we do suggest sometimes that people use it topically if they have an open wound at their cancer.
So if they have a breast cancer that's come to the surface and it's weeping using Rick Simpson oil,
typically can have some great benefits because you're getting it right to the cancer directly.
So that could have some great benefits.
If you don't have an open wound using it topically, Rick Simpson oil doesn't tend to absorb well through the skin.
So it's very messy, it's very tar-like as I have said,
and it doesn't absorb the greatest through the skin.
So it's not something we would necessarily recommend to use topically.
Now, if you added a something as a driver to it, then that might be an option.
But still, I don't know that I would use it topically unless you did have an open wound that you could get at it.
So next question.
Question that about histamine and cancer.
With this question, I get to refer you to our blog post and just go to countersclinic.com and look at the blogs and there's a blog that how does histamine connect to cancer.
And there's a research article that I talk about that with histamine and glioblastoma brain tumors and cancers.
But there's other articles, other things that reference in there and articles are referenced in there about breast cancer as well.
There's some research that came out a couple of years ago and I wrote a blog post about it with breast cancer as well.
We always think of histamine as a bad thing. So we take antihistamine during allergy season.
So histamine must be a bad thing. But remember, all these things that our body creates histamine is something that's created by our immune response is has a purpose.
So histamine itself is not a bad thing. You have different antibody or excuse me, different enzymes in your gut that are made by different genes in your gut that make enzymes to break down histamines that enzyme is called DAO enzyme that breaks down histamine in the gut.
And it's made by the DAO gene that's in your gut. And if a person has a genetic issue, we need to have genetic defects other DAO genes, they don't make a lot of the DAO enzyme in that person can be more prone to having histamine issues because they're not breaking down histamines from their diet.
So I said our body makes histamines, but we also ingest histamines. So histamines are in foods and on our website on the blog, we have a histamine food list that lists out all the different foods that have high histamines.
So what a person's going on a low histamine diet. You are just doing that. You're going on a low histamine diet. You can't you can't not eat any histamines. There's histamines in everything. It's a matter of eating things that have a lower quantity of histamines.
Nuts, really good for you cashews and walnuts and things like that. Good for your good protein, a good fat source, but they have a lot of histamines strawberry strawberries are good for us, but strawberries have a lot of histamines beads have a lot of histamines
Lunge meat has a lot of histamines and even if you make a chicken dinner and you eat it tonight, but you left the leftovers of the fridge. It's going to have more histamines.
The longer it sits in the fridge. So if you're eating a leftover, that's going to have more histamines in it than if you ate it fresh.
So histamines are not something you can eliminate. Histamines are something that you can decrease.
Now, if your body makes a lot of DAO enzyme in the gut, you don't really have a lot of histamine issues from histamines that are ingested.
Histamines are also made in the tissues. They're made in the body. Histamines serve a purpose as an immune indicator. So as an immediate immune response, the histamines basically signal other immune cells to come to an area.
So if you're exposed to a lot of pollen, you breathe in that pollen dust that goes into the tissues and you'll have an immediate histamine reaction.
Now, why do some people have a worse histamine reaction than others? Therefore, they have seasonal allergies.
Well, the truth is they don't necessarily have a worst issue than others. It's just that they don't clear histamine as well as a person who doesn't have seasonal allergies.
So a person that has seasonal allergies doesn't clear histamine in the tissues very well. There's another gene your H and M T gene that actually makes an enzyme at DAO enzyme in the tissues that clears and breaks down histamine that's made in the presence of an antigen like pollen that you are exposed to.
So when you're exposed to something that stimulates your immune system, and it causes a histamine reaction normally people their H and H and M T, H and M T gene makes this DAO enzyme that breaks down that histamine and gets rid of it and the person does not have quote unquote allergies.
But a person that has defects in that gene doesn't make as much as that enzyme and they don't break it down very fast and they end up having a hyper histamine reaction.
So what do you do for those things, those people that have that issue, and what do you do for a person that maybe histamine is driving their cancer? Now, if you're like, well, I don't know if histamine is driving my cancer.
We tested every single person whether histamine is driving their cancer, so you would have been told that. However, the truth is, is even though histamine might not be driving your cancer, it can be problematic. So decrease the amount of high histamine foods one eats or decrease the exposures to antigens that can cause access histamines or even utilizing an anti histamine drug or an anti histamine supplement can be beneficial.
So quercetin, stinging nettles, even curcumin can decrease histamines. We have a product called clear hiss natural clear hiss, which is a histamine reducing supplement that can be beneficial to reduce histamines in the tissues.
There's also a histamine enzyme. You can literally take the DAO enzyme. Now, you won't absorb that, but it will break down histamines of the tissues. So people that have really bad gut issues due to histamines, which really aren't any of our cancer patients. Those would be an autoimmune patient, but they can take that histamine.
And that's called histic clear. That's our product. And that is actually the DAO enzyme. So that would break down histamines in the gut from foods that you're ingesting.
So that's just a little bit more than you probably want to know about histamines. Look up on our blog. We also have multiple web pages on histamines. Just do a search on our website for histamine, and you'll see a bunch of pages that I go into even more boring detail that I just gave you on histamines.
Question came in. It said what about RSO on cancerous skin lesions that are not open. Could it be mixed with a carrier for a large area lesions are at the site of mastectomy incision. So back to the RSO. Yes, you could use a carrier that could help bring it in.
You could, that's a possibility. You're just not going to have great absorption through the skin.
If you don't have an open wound, you're just not going to have great absorption with RSO. But it's still, but if we tested with Kadeziology and a tested for beneficial, well, then by all means do it.
But just to use it in general, you're not going to have great absorption to wipe a little bit on it.
The nice thing about being a tarry is that it will stick there and it will stay there.
It's probably going to stay in any clothing that it gets in contact with. So I wouldn't be careful of that. Maybe put a little bandaid type or gauze patch over it.
It's certainly worth trying. There isn't a thread. I don't know that you'll get a lot of absorption.
Okay, next question was about sprouting seeds and using sprouts.
Are they beneficial? Do they have the ability to carry mold?
The answer is, so the second question, do they have a capacity to carry mold?
Not if you're cleaning your seed sprouting tray. No, not really at all.
My suggestion is that you eat, if you're going to do sprouts that you do try to eat them within 10 to 12 days, like wheat sprouts do not have gluten in them until after 10 to 12 days.
So wheat sprouts are gluten free. That's why you can see some wheat grass that is in some products and the products has gluten free.
But it's got wheat grass and barley grass in there. How in the world could that be gluten free? Cause I know wheat barley are have gluten in it.
If it's the grass and it's picked or cut and utilize prior to 10 to 12 days, it does not have any gluten in it.
So if you want fresh your sprouts, so don't think you're going to try to save and your sprouts are getting kind of older looking, you know, just clean the tray and start over with new sprouts.
So sprouts can be beneficial. Sprouts can have a lot of nutrient value in it, just like microgreens. That's really what sprouts really are, microgreens kind of things.
They can have a lot of good nutrients in it and they can be beneficial.
Similar question was about using oil diffusers. This is a picture of a diffuser here. Does it have the capability of having mold?
So the answer is not really and you can say the same thing about your tray here. Now there may be some like this is a plastic tray for sprouting.
Bold needs water, so it needs moisture. Well, I'm watering these sprouts. So that's moisture, but mold also needs a food and the food needs to be typically a water paper product.
So that's why mold grows on your walls, because you have sheet rock other walls, which is plaster and covered with a paper.
So it's a perfect environment if it's wet, like it's getting damp from frost because it's a poorly insulated wall, or there's a leak behind the wall and it's wetting the back of the sheet rock, the paper is wet.
Now it's a perfect environment for mold to grow.
And there's mold spores pretty much ubiquitous everywhere. And if they're given the perfect environment, they can grow. Now typically you're not going to get mold growing on the surface of a diffuser because most diffusers are either ceramic or their plastic.
So there's nothing for the mold to feed on. So well, there's water there. There's moisture there. No, you're going to get mildew. You might get some fungus.
You're not going to get mold per se like a black mold. It's a dangerous mold. But do clean this. I have this diffuser that I bought. I can't remember where I got it, but it's a great big one. It's not this one. I couldn't find the picture of this big one.
But it holds about a quarter and a half of water, maybe a little bit more, almost two quarts of water. And it's nice because it'll run for at least on high, it'll run for at least 12 to 14 hours.
And on low, it'll run for a day and a half.
So it's really nice. I use that. We have a couple of those at our house. And even with those big water-cutting diffusers, I only put about maybe seven drops of oil in it.
And I don't always use oil just getting moisture in the house in Minnesota is beneficial. But these smaller diffusers make sure you're only putting three to five drops of oil.
And remember, essential oils are powerful there. They can be stronger than any herbs. So they can be, they can, they can overwhelm your immune system in your body too. And they can be harsh on your liver.
So some people that are really into essential oils can actually get me damaging their liver. So just be careful with essential oils as you're not overdoing essential oils.
I'm putting some lemon grass or frakin sense or something like that in a diffuser like this can be very beneficial.
You could certainly, you know, run it if you're not using more than three to five drops of oil, you can be running at 24 seven.
Just making sure you clean this every few days just to make sure that you're not developing, you know, any mildew or something in there.
And then if you have hard water, you'll develop some calcium deposits in there. So make sure you're scrumming those often and cleaning those.
There really is no harm or no with hard water as using hard water in your diffuser. It's just that you're going to have to clean it a little bit more off.
Okay, now that brings us to an open forum. So I'm going to stop the recording on this.